you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
could hydrogen be a fuel of the future a
new research facility is testing the
practicalities
we look at how green the gas really is
huge damage done to wildlife and
ecosystems is revealed as
wildfires in northern ireland are
brought under control
and the 24 year old kuwaiti woman giving
out plants in exchange for recycling
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come and great britain has already made
significant progress
increasing the amount of electricity
produced from renewable sources and if
we look at our data dashboard
you can see today that's at around 39
percent
but that's just electricity production
of the uk's homes are connected to the
gas grid meaning
they use natural gas a fossil fuel for
things like
heating and cooking well hydrogen is
often cited as a possible alternative
and now a new research facility
is testing how existing infrastructure
and houses can be adapted
to use it well in a moment we'll hear
from our correspondent lisa holland
who's had exclusive
access to the site but first how green
is hydrogen
hydrogen hydrogen hydrogen
[Music]
clean hydrogen
[Applause]
[Music]
so how would hydrogen work in your home
well sky's climate correspondent lisa
holland has been finding out
i'm in a remote part of cumbria at the
uk's first
hydrogen testing facility pipes are
being laid
work is being carried out to try to
establish
how the existing gas network can be
repurposed
to use hydrogen now this test site
they've also got
a set of mocks up houses a row of houses
the kind of property that you'd find
in any town or city across the uk
and the idea with these houses is to try
to show
how hydrogen could be pumped into a
house
uh and the customer would really not
even notice the difference in the same
way that gases
at the moment so a hydrogen boiler which
would heat the house
a kettle a toaster and
all the things that you might cook all
powered
using hydrogen now currently around 30
of our emissions come from the home so
how we heat all our homes and what we do
in our homes
is crucial if witness to get to net zero
more than 80 percent of homes in the uk
currently have
a gas supply so there seems to be a high
level of confidence that
the existing gas network can be
repurposed
for hydrogen use but there are big
question marks
about how the development would be
funded in the future
and how a green clean supply
of hydrogen would be developed as well
but
this is what your home could look like
in the future
as part of the road to net zero sitting
at a dinner table
uh eating food that's cooked using
hydrogen and in a house that's warm with
the use of hydrogen
as well well joining me now is sandalae
matetoix who's a phd candidate in
chemistry at the university of cambridge
welcome to you the site that lisa
holland was visiting there is testing
the use of
gray hydrogen but that's not
particularly green to produce is it
well it's not because gray hydrogen is
pretty much well known for
high carbon emissions so that really
disputes the idea of it being green
well yes and it can be used hydrogen can
be produced using
renewable energy can't it so is that
practical or
would you then say why not just use
renewable energy and cut out hydrogen
all together
well i mean that's the thing so green
hydrogen uh would mean
you know net zero carbon emissions and
at the moment
we are really not at a stage of having
green hydrogen
um but what's happening more now is you
know for example natural gas reforming
where you do produce hydrogen and carbon
dioxide
by capturing the carbon dioxide and
storing it so that's carbon capture and
storage
and utilization could actually be the
the first step into you know
a more less carbon intensive um
source of hydrogen so in terms of green
hydrogen we are not
there but blue hydrogen which is a
carbon capture and storage utilization
is probably the best way to go now
and the uk government has made it clear
that they feel that hydrogen will play a
big part
in their ambitions to reach net zero so
how do you
envisage the country using and adopting
hydrogen over the years to come
to what extent do you think it will be
picked up um well i
i would think maybe a pretty much a big
extent
depending on you know how much how much
research and how much funding is putting
to the research that goes into green
hydrogen
because at the moment we have
electrolysis if you are familiar
electrolysis is a process where you are
splitting water
using electricity and the water is split
into its constituent hydrogen and oxygen
components
so uh this this process if you are using
electricity sourced from
say solar power or wind power could
potentially be green hydrogen
electrolysis is is at a good stage a
more advanced stage really
and i think that if if a lot of input is
put into
uh using um you know solar power or wind
power for
for generating electricity electricity
to power electrolysis that could be the
best way
sunderland thank you let's take a look
now at some of the day's other climate
news and the majority of people in the
uk
want the government to introduce green
taxes a survey
by britain thinks and the green alliance
found nearly two-thirds of britain's
support taxing environmentally damaging
behaviour
it comes just days after boris johnson
set out a new emissions
target pledging to reduce the uk's
carbon footprint by
78 by 2035.
[Applause]
mi6 is monitoring other countries to
make sure they're keeping to their
climate change commitments
the agency's chief richard moore said
british spies have started to watch
large industrialized countries like
china to check their progress
he believes the climate crisis should be
at the forefront of every country's
foreign policy and more than 60
retailers say they'll halve their carbon
emissions by 2030.
boohoo primark and asos are amongst the
fashion brands that have
signed up to the sustainable action plan
each company will look at improving the
durability and recyclability of their
clothing range
now since friday areas of the mourne
mountains in northern ireland have
suffered
huge wildfires with a major incident
declared
and more than 100 firefighters tackling
the flames
the operation has been scaled back today
as the blaze was brought under control
but it's thought the fires have had a
devastating impact on the wildlife and
biodiversity
in the area well dr neil reed is a
senior lecturer in conservation biology
at queen's university belfast he joins
me now
dr reed just how much damage are these
fires
doing to the mountains i mean it's an
important habitat isn't it for plants
and animals
well that's right the moon mountains are
an area of outstanding natural beauty so
first of all
they serve a real function with respect
to people going to these landscapes and
enjoying these landscapes
but also they're designated for their
habitats and their wildlife they're a
special area of conservation for their
upland
heathland and peatland habitats and uh
unfortunately we're no stranger to these
fires nowadays they are becoming
increasingly frequent we have had a
string of very dry spring weather from
um so we've had multiple years that have
been very dry and we've had these fires
before we know that they have
devastating effects
on wildlife so at this time of year we
would expect for example ground nesting
birds to be
in the middle of their nesting season
meadow pipettes skylarks
red grouse frogs have just spawned
earlier and are out and about
we have lizards coming out of
hibernation we have all of the bees and
and the butterflies and the dragonflies
coming out at this time of year which
will have unfortunately been killed over
a large area so this wildfire covered
just over two and a half just under
three square kilometers
and it's an area that has been burnt
before so we have the succession of
events
where each time we lose wildlife that we
had before that doesn't then
subsequently recolonize
and so there's kind of this slow
attrition of of wildlife over time
what about the broader implications for
the environment as well because these
areas have the ability to store carbon
don't they
so absolutely peatlands are decomposed
plants
over tens of thousands of years that
have captured carbon dioxide through
photosynthesis out of the atmosphere and
have locked it away in the soil
so obviously you want these peatlands to
function and to continue
performing that function of carbon
sequestration and storage
because it helps the uk and ireland meet
their targets
uh under international agreements to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions because
we're sucking it out of the atmosphere
and locking it into the soils but what
these fires do of course is turn the
tables
they instantly release um hundreds
thousands of years of carbon dioxide
that have been stored up
by combustion and so releasing it so
back into the atmosphere
and so it's this positive feedback loop
where these wildfires
contribute to global climate change
which causes then
further strange weather to occur for
this run of very dry springs and we
expect droughts to continue into the
future
they expect to be more frequent deeper
and longer
dr neil reed thanks very much indeed
now for the latest in our series of
climate diaries and today we're hearing
from fatima alzheimer who's trying to
persuade people in kuwait
to embrace recycling up to 90 percent of
waste in the country ends up in landfill
something fatima is determined to change
[Applause]
my name is fatima zazila the founder of
ikesa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
exchanger for recyclable to get a tree
[Music]
the inspiration came from the tv show
however
by mr ahmed shigeri who
had an episode about pollution in
general and he was talking about waste
pollution and how can we solve it
and fight it through recycling as a way
to cover this type of crimes what i wish
for
is to move toward this solution
and to act for nature
[Music]
that's everything from us for today on
the daily climate show tomorrow how
restoring wetlands can help
wildlife and tackle the impacts of
climate change
thanks for watching and we'll see you
[Music]
then
you